when I married Marjorie I had something
but we didn't do it pretty much because
I knew this is the trick I'm going to
the table
[Applause]
opinion um I understand the religious
point of view where it's like okay you
know you don't want to plan for
something to fail
but we are supposed to be
virgins it's like all these
says my religion says I can't do a
prenup well how
religion also says you're supposed to be
a virgin on your wedding day and the
point is just it's like blatant
hypocrisy like women want traditionalism
but only when it benefits us
um so okay we're not gonna bring
virginity but that's okay we have a pass
Sorry God here I go down the aisle um
now I'm even gonna bring a kid I'm even
gonna bring a child but a prenup that's
that's where I draw the line